[Musica]
io mi sto già cagano addosso è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo momento io
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo finalmente
saumont the sleep ragazzo è uscito
finalmente a montese dopo circa un anno
che che mi martellava te sul farlo
quindi spero siete contenti anche perché
sono molto contento anch'io appena
iniziano comunque ragazzi credo che la
demo l'abbiate vista nel caso ve la
lascio nelle annotazioni che vedete
sempre in alto nel video direi che
possiamo cominciare così almeno vediamo
di che si tratta perché sono cioè è uno
dei giochi che ho atteso di più penso
anche voi perché me ne sono accorto dato
che me lo consigliava te tutti comunque
che sembra di essere in bocca sei fumato
qualche canna qualcuno cos'è ragazzi
sembra sembra di essere un pesce in una
boccia tesoro e bevuto tutto no ma
perciò ho buttato attento potrebbero
anche se mi sa che sempre lotta va bè
non importa ancora minuto ma deve
controllare che la sorte sia pronta
ragazzi sono un bambino ma ma tra
inutile porta pila tolta subito che sono
affamato ragazzi sta per ricevere una
torta che lo sia la nutella lotto di
ragazzi io io io già mosto gioco ma
guardate che un questo pigiamino 6
adorabile grazie mille
non è qui qualcuno vuole un po di forza
se io voglio la porta io voglio lo so
c'è anche c'è anche cc
ok ma non deve prendermi per un
deficiente cioè ho capito dammi torta e
stai zitta che ha bussato qualcuno ha
bussato io intanto mi magno la torta va
ad aprire donna io mangio tutto è una
cosa comunque non diceva ragazzi voglio
mangiare la torta da solo senza mia
madre e la rega che cazzo succede c'è
terremoto c'è il terremoto cosa magari
sto per vomitare non storica che cazzo
sta succedendo non si capisce chi è
mamma vogliono già dato a un regalo per
me c'era bisogno di fare sto casino lei
trovato a caso fuori dalla porta perché
noi andiamo lì sopra vedere che cos'è il
mio regalo sarà il mio iphone 5 perché
il mio iphone 4 è troppo datato quindi
volevo quello nuovo o certo contattarmi
mangiato è già scoppiato peso chiamato
non ho mangiato due pezzi mio dio è una
cosa detta io ti mette volentieri le
dita nel naso però non questa fa passi
avanti regala ma mamma è certo è che la
roba ma ma io cioè mai pulito per caso
stamattina presenza ragazzi stiamo
stiamo andando non so dove che vede in
camera mia facevo le stuprarmi era e
monk e slip perfetto ragazzi voglio
capire come mai mi st cerci della roba
nera che sale le scale è più utile forte
un'edizione quella roba ci raggiunge
chiudono ti metto le dita nel naso
eccoci qui perfetto vediamo un po cosa
c'è dentro forse un nuovo giocattolo ma
io volevo l'iphone 5 è una cosa
è un pupazzo di merda no io potevo le
voci che fan culo perché il tesoro della
mamma fai la brava resta che giocare la
mamma torna subito ma vabbè io io io
gioco alla playstation
grazie mille dove cazzo e me mi ha messo
in cella sono in prigioniero ma non
manca in auto aste sono in gabbia
maledizione dei premuto le mans per
raccogliere un oggetto perfetto ragazzi
sono un bambino di due anni il che vuol
dire che posso toccare le tette della
mamma senza che si incazza io vi porto
si cosi perchè mi piace left control per
gattonare ah beh questo lo sa per
ragazzi un pochettino i comandi me li
ricordo dalla demo usa spacey farò
arrampicarti a mi arrampico madonna ma
sotto bambino è un ninja c'è la grande
vi chiama evadere di prigione come
niente non so se andare a fare cazzate
in giro o prefetto un cerchio cazzo sul
caduto perfetto mi sono ammazzato ma non
fa niente mo di temi che c'è un iphone o
un android nascosto qua dentro e non
solo quel pupazzo di merda dove se ne
fotto qualcuno se io e tanto piu e
cuscini a caso
eccoti più brutto stronzo ragazzi di
state vedendo anche voi ragazzi io mi
chiamo the videos e riconosciuti i nuovi
ti chiami la piacere io sono fa vj
ascoltarmi e death in sei molto gentile
e simpatico vedo però io volevo un
iphone tu faccia un gioco cosa sei saw
l'enigmista sa se facciamo che tutti i
volti non nasconda d'elefante rosa che
cazzo sta succedendo regala ragazzi ma
sto bambino nelle l'omogeneizzato ci
mettono le canne unipi girati a
coprirgli il procedimento premi esco per
capirti gli occhi asili che figo
deprimenti ragazzi proprio dai menu dopo
chiudermi gli occhi una bellissima sta
cosa
riprendi posto a fede ora puoi guardare
grazie mille dove sei ma dove mai avrei
nascosto quel pupazzetto rosa molto
carino giuro che non hai da lì dove
possa averlo messo ma guarda c'è
qualcosa che spunta da dietro la cassa
sarà mica quello marcatura
stai giocando con un professionista
parole sfogliatore alla grande e credimi
è forte mi a cavalluccio voglio precise
dare una scossa
ragazzi questo vuole stuprarmi io ti
prendo a causa lucio con 7 ci serve un
posto molto buio che negli armadi o
ragazzi sto pupazzo un pedofilo non
capito
vabbè comunque io apro l'armadio deve
essere più buio chiuse nelle anse va
bene è chiuso
adesso questa roba da sputi effetto cui
si dovrebbe andare noi ragazzi possiamo
pero non ci siano mostri qui lo spero
anche io perché potrei prendermi male ti
troverai in un posto buio come questo
avrei paura abbraccia miste resto si
farà sentire protetta vuole una femmina
io non avrò le tette stai tranquillo
quindi riflettere pronto f per
abbracciare termine spingerlo a figo
sull'abbraccio si vede di più ha quindi
e quindi lui tifa una torcia
ok ragazzi e io non so cosa si sta
avvicinando ma io stringo tetti forte
nel dubbio posso uscire questo ci guarda
tu non vorrei mai stato è stato lui è
stato voi giocate contro un amichetto sì
ma è mio ma del signor rosso pianciani
conosciuto come è stata chiamata lurida
che cazzo perché smetterla di
nasconderti dalla mamma non ho io voglio
nascondermi perché tu non mi mostri la
testa quindi non molto e spero sia stato
un bel compleanno male ci sia stato un
bel compleanno ma adesso andiamo al sodo
e adesso ora di andare a nanna no non
voglio fare la nanna voglio andare a
giocare con te ti molla ministronza se
vai a letto subito domani poi alzarsi
per estendere a giocare con l'amico
tutto il giorno ok
li attendiamo a dormire prima che
qualcuno buonanotte tesoro buonanotte
mamma per ritornare senza regista in una
prossima rimasta musichetta non mi fa
addormentare vi fa cagare addosso ma
sono sono sveglio ragazzi mi sono
svegliato nel mezzo della notte perché
io non volevo dormire
io gliel'avevo detto ce n'è a portarci
alla porta semiaperta perfetto mi piace
stare qua dentro brutto the di dammi la
mano fa qualcosa non lo so è di diritti
e di sta tentando di scappare nomi st
grazie paranormal activity queste
paranormal tuo pazzo era dio mio santo
che è successo cioè è stato portato via
da qualche entità mistica non so come
sia possibile ma va bene così belli
scelti che cazzo fai ragazzi che cosa
sta facendo sotto pupazzo stupido ma tu
credi
porca [ __ ] lo sapevo che non devo
lasciarti libero lurida è sparito teddy
a caso va bè non importa allora
veramente ragazzi sta parte qui era
anche nella demo più o meno che forse
l'hanno cambiata un po non lo so però la
demo iniziava a sto punto qui comunque a
trovare teddy che adesso anche dove
perché me lo ricordo dalla demo che era
quad ed era nella lavatrice
ecco infatti vista che è ancora lì
dentro dai 10 salvo io sei tranquillo
afferma eccoci qua ci sia ed in tutto a
posto
ecco grassi c'è cosa sogni era un dato
di oltre la tua madre come c'è qualcosa
che non va che è stato chi è stato a
prenderti ragazzi sto pupazzo mi fa più
paura che altro ma non importano via
potenza
devo andare 18 a vedere dove vediamo è
finita a mia madre perché sennò è un
casino con casa dove la palla eccola la
palla me la porto perché mia e mi piace
ecco perfetto dovunque vado alla palla
me la porto perché non dobbiamo farci
sentire non si sa mai chi potrebbe
ascoltarci andiamo in cucina prima che
succeda qualcosa di brutto non so cosa
però assoluto più veloce senga bono
porca [ __ ] dai in piedi che ad ogni tre
secondi maledizione
mi piace mancava solo che piovesse
perfetto bisogno di andare di caprino
che i pomodori sono malvagi perché di
pomodori anno anno sono mele che cosa
sono sti cosi a nome le mele sono meta
circa rotto il naso ragazza a casa e
posseduto amica non so se è normale però
va bene non mi ricordo che cosa c'è
perché tipo ho giocato due a due secoli
fa la demo poi la demo genere mi che
avesse un caduto addosso perché mettono
le scarpe sotto i vestiti si dia
vincenti ai 100 rumori bruttissimo non
idea di che cosa sia ma non mi piace per
niente cos'è sta roba sul muro che cazzo
succede ragazze qualcuno è entrato per
caso in casa in caso di buoni e andiamo
avanti prima che fece tanto ormai so già
che che qualcosa non sta andando per il
verso giusto perché tutto aperto
continuo a non capire se mia madre che
gironzola oppure se qualcuno è entrato
in casa che era che non lo so arga anzi
pure a gia vero ragazzi s'è mosso
qualcosa [ __ ] non c'arriva la maniglia
maledizione ma devo salire qua sopra
credo a rega devo ricorrere le mie doti
da ninja perché se non riesco a salire
che non ancora così so dov'è finito
teddy perché non è possibile non c'è più
chiaramente ragazzi non mi ricordo come
avevo fatto però che credo si faccia
così 3 2 1 per dare l'esploratrice ma
parte ma che cazzo sono caduto in una
maniera atroce cioè non è posto a farsi
qua mezz'ora per riuscirci c'è dio mio
e la cosa non mi ricordavo neanche come
avevo fatto nel abbiamo provato di nuovo
per mezz'ora chi è che chi è che sarà
qua dentro prima luride tela qualcuno
qui sotto non so chi ma c'era qualcuno
ci prova ok ma cosa cazzo cazzo via
puntale veloci veloci
non so chi cazzo non ho idea di chi
abbia aperto la porta ma qualcuno l'ha
aperta per forza quindi successo filippo
che chiami a mia madre dovrebbe essere
nel letto però non c'è non c'è non è
possibile cioè l'unica ma che cazzo stai
mangiando sto bambina senza intenti tra
i denti sevani oddio potrei chiederlo
con le mani volendo le cause che questo
questo questo più o meno me lo ricordavo
però non me lo ricordavo per niente lega
ma non importa
andiamo andiamo avanti perché io non ho
ancora capito chi è quel tizio comunque
va bene
c'è poi tra l'altro la televisione era
accesa prima mou è spenta vanno con noi
c'è qualcuno in casa che non ho visto
comunque devo andare ecco perfetto di
bambù si apre così bene ragazzi cè un
portale però prima di andarci mi porta
la mia valigetta perché sono un bimbo
d'affari 15 ho bisogno
vai valigia prima tutto perfetto ok sono
salvo non è morta la valigia con i non
morirò neanch'io perfetto
chi è quel tizio c'è qualcuno che è in
ginocchio ma è lei assomiglia più a un
ricordo
ricordo di mia mamma quello che ci aveva
sulle tette me lo ricordo bene prendiamo
che grazie mamma
l'ondata
[Applauso]
è un sogno cosa ma dove cazzo se siamo
in cantina in poche parole però non ho
capito bene perché non so se sia fumato
una canna o se mangio omogenizzati
scaduti ma qualcosa di strano c'è ci
siamo ragazzi sto per tuffarmi non so
non chiedetemi dove sono andato non lo
so però è che qualcosa di sicuramente
figo ma stai bene
sì sto bene ma dove cazzo se infinite
una casetta dei giochi che cosa ci fa
qui ragazzi sto bambino si è fumato
qualcosa ma di pesante io lo dico sono
ancora ne diviach e che hanno uno stop i
tenendo tra identità attento che accade
nei cieli quasi era rimasto che dovevamo
trovare mia madre poi siamo scesi in
stop non so da dove però va beh questo
non si apre e chissà chiave fa se questa
aprirla dall'interno se mi aiuti a
salire perfetto vai vai tu vai tu bra
bravo the di file ninja file ninja
compito dovere da ninja stupido pupazzo
vai dentro bravo così perfetto ragazzi
io e te dico qui staremo al mondo il
giorno e ancora non ho capito perché
siamo certi si fa vedere accordo ragazzi
ray che possono chiudere qui il primo
episodio comunque presto a richiamare la
parte più o meno per capire come non i
comandi ma che dalla prossima diciamo
che gli infarti vinceranno a sentirsi
parecchio per la mia gioia tutti ragazzi
come al solito se il video è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche la
faceva di facebook come veniva trovata
una descrizione sono stati altri siti
scrivete noi ci rimettiamo al prossimo
video della ragazzi